Now that you've had a chance to graph, it's my turn. Let's see if I can do this
right. Because it works better for my brain, I've transferred all the data on
the table to coordinate notation on the right-hand side of the table. That just
helps me graph better, personally. So, I'm going to plot these points. We step
over 3 in the negative direction on the x-axis, and down 14. Now, you want to
make sure that the points, when you graph them on graph paper, as we saw in the
previous example, are as accurately placed as possible. So luckily, for the
scale that we've chosen for this graph and this equation, all of these points
should lie directly on intersection points of vertical and horizontal lines on
the graph paper. So, that's awesome. Negative 2, negative 11, and you can see I
just made a mistake again. I forgot that we were counting by two's in the y
direction, and I placed a point at 2,2 instead of 2,1. So, I've graphed a fair
number of graphs in my life. So, if you make a mistake doing this, it's not a
big deal at all. We just have to make sure we correct ourselves. And lastly, we
have 3,4. Okay, great. These look to me like they're all in a pretty straight
line, so let's get our ruler to make sure. I think we're safe. Let's connect
them. And we have a gorgeous line that I will now draw an arrow on either end
of. Remember, this arrow shows this line is extending forever out in either
direction, continuing its pattern for all values of x. I've also drawn an arrow
on either end of this line to show that it extends forever out in both
directions.